creato da mark jacques un ragazzo che ha
solo fatto un gioco va bene belle tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a che siano video
sono fa vj pedaggi siamo tornati su
kazan glory che posso dire
tranquillamente tanto nessuno crede che
sia una parolaccia aiutarti su cassa in
glory che sarebbe la versione 3d di è
più il avevo fatto nell'ultimo episodio
diversi livelli e voglio provare a
vedere se riesco a farne altri visto che
ce ne sono tipo 10 e ne ho fatti tre
ho capito ma dammi un attimo
un'indicazione che doveva tipo heidi
seguo le colline va bene che bello
questo gioco mi dà sempre soddisfazione
comunque volevo dirvi ragazzi che lo
scorso episodio ha fatto un sacco di mi
piace perché è effettivamente il gioco
di è più visti in 3d più figuri abbia
mai visto
cioè vedete quanto è figo l'arco che mi
spara in faccia e ovvio fa bene e devo
raggiungere in tutto questo il traguardo
che non ho capito ancora dovevano sto
andando tutto storto ci puoi fare frate
o che vede che non era difficile ma
quando ci sono gli archi è che ha
piazzato ste cose che sparano frecce in
giro brutti stronzi e basta che palle
epa per non ci credo percorso nord ma
dai ma non è vero ha colpito mio figlio
non me la cosa nella quale credo vi
siano accorti tutti quanti e che leggerà
napo leggermente più difficile rieti
questo gioco del casinò ok il traguardo
è laggiù ragazzi ce la posso fare fermi
come scendo eve perfetto mi sono
risposto da solo non ti schiantare con è
bravo bravo bravissimo doveva è meglio
di così non potevo uscire perfetto vai
vai vai veloce veloce veloce grande
ok meno male che era veri visto livello
che stavo andando schiantarmi blue and
superduper ce l'ho fatta va bene non so
come va bene bellissimi studio livelli
ragazzi una giornata nel parco è una
giornata nel parco con una sega prova a
fare quella con la sega bello si
preannuncia un livello molto figo valle
perché ci è passata una sega a ok la
secolare perfetti fantastico almeno
risparmiamo sulla macelleria ragazzi ora
che la [ __ ] che casi non fosse così
difficile sto gioco anche se basta
avanotti impennare idiota
sono vivo fra vivo fermi la mia gamba
cosa è successo sono vivo o la gamba un
pò incastrata però sono vivo importante
quello
caput pazza ladra dall'altra parte
perfetto per lui è la madonna come fa
passare sugli scalini sugli scalini sono
scarso ma si può essere così scabrosi
sono vivo per la devi smettere di
contraddirmi e gioco della minkia veloce
veloce veloce fantastico vedi che non
aiuti difficile il traguardo è qua se in
scemo albe che devo farmi ovviamente
tutto il giro se non è contento
fantastico posso devo andare ancora lì
pur chiama accalai da ce l'ho fatta ce
l'ho fatta perfetto ma chi è
stavolta volevo prendere la lama non ci
sono risposte cestino chi è un killer di
cestini ragazzi warm up o passiamo dal
molto facile al facile che conoscendo il
gioco non so quanto in realtà possa
essere facile però qual è la difficoltà
di suo livello cosa mi cadono gli alieni
in testa cos'è sta roba oddio quando
vedo le rampe e mi spavento tutto bene
guaina sprite una red bull a robot ex è
ripresa e ha avuto un mancamento ragazzi
perché va beh non avrà lasciato dislike
ai miei video poi perché ci siamo
arrivati ragazzi e ogni volta ci stavo
giusto dicendo ogni volta che c'è un
check point poi schiatto immediatamente
dopo un secolo niente neanche il secondo
è passato applicazione
c'è un pallone [ __ ] novità visto ciò
cosa che spara palle ma basta ma cos'è
da oggi walker ok madonna che travolge e
vabbè il palo ci manca solo quello
perché mi devono far andare fuori strada
dei palloni che non so privato vai
veloce schiva della prof ero finito ho
vinto
a chi è quanto è stato difficile se
contento figlio che abbiamo vinto
va bè ragazzi ha provato un sacco
cappella fai il mica come sto bene
l'inglese john e tim hill ai proviamoci
dove devo andare
ci costate cal non sono anche partito
calmi calmi
lo devo andare per
e l'emozione per riuscire bravissimo
perfetta società andare dritto ma che
cazzo chi è che fa esplodere le mine
sono vivo ho perso una mano e ho perso
una mano ma sono vivo però se mi
colpisce un pallone muoio quindi io devo
farmi tutta questa strada senza che
qualcuno colpisca le micce è impossibile
fermi fermi che ce la sto facendo ora
lenti pam nicchia che morte bruttissima
no non ho le mie l'emilia loro schivate
tutte dietro dietro dietro dietro
perfetto dietro di nuovo fantastico ho
preso per il culo il gioco sono riuscito
quando tentò di fare gli escamotage
ginger faccio una figura di merda ogni
volta ma stavolta grazie a dio sono
riuscito ad andare
minchia una rampa alla fine o quanto di
odio non saltarli mine cosa sta facendo
e scemo cosa cazzo e su big mappe da
iwata colpito un piede in altri vst
italiano metta corpo se è ancora vivo
qua mi chiama stato prendere il tallone
veramente queste a killer veloce che non
ci passi sono dei clip che poi non è
betclic piazza la cosa a 360 fenomeno le
faccio ma non so come si chiamano e
faqih est
ce l'ho fatta ragazzi sono morto subito
dopo ma va bene un flash ma portate
mettere lì non mi facili da ricordare
porca eva mica io voglio usare la
famiglia rega e bellissimo the barrel
rowling quando sei in aria premia ed io
prima ho fatto un 360 non è la stessa
cosa
porca eva come partito mio figlio sono
ancora vivo in teoria cioè non mi ha
colpito alla una prova pratica ma che
vediamo vediamo vediamo vediamo
che cazzo è successo un lampione ma dai
ma non ci credo torna indietro veloce ho
mica un ciabot non ci sto non ci sto
credo insomma mi vien da piangere guarda
ma c'è un muro li suo muro licia muro o
dio va bene allora siete scemi a dovevo
fare il barrel roll sono stupido dritto
dritto
ok ok perfetto devo girarmi adesso devo
fare tipo così ce l'ho fatta sono fatta
però c'è diritto vai dritto a non andare
storto tutto ubriaco lui meraviglio ti
amo ti amo ti adoro
oddio che casino che cosa succede
non l'ho preso sarebbe stato etico ahia
vabbè ragazzi visto che abbiamo appurato
che leggermente difficile proviamo a
fare un paragone con è più il signor se
c'è più visse in 3d proprio però vorrei
ah non lo so è però provo a fare una
roba tipo di impossible non lo so perché
è la cosa più difficile che ci faccio un
confronto con ep lewis quello originale
tra troppa ci sarà quel impossible più
minchia 1.400.000 place e il welcome to
impossible challenge piace è difficile
ma devo far canestro
mica punto ci si vuole far canestro
incazzate na cazzata
non è una cazzata fermi un attimo vorrei
mi sta prendendo per il culo hai visto
te l'avevo detto veloce non ce la faccio
[ __ ] sherrod ai fermi ce la posso
fare che non è possibile sono riuscito a
fare quello col barre roll quello con la
rampa non posso non far questo già
assurdo perfetto perfetto mi chiama e
vabbè ma non può entrare il pallone ce
l'ha presa per il culo fermi
vai vai vai veloce veloce veloce ma non
c'è niente non entrò un cazzo stavo
scherzando ragazzi questo è assoluta ok
niente entrati impossible 70 per cento è
stato difficile il problema è che è sta
roba
ok forse ho sbagliato a fare a cercare
proprio l'impossible perché mi ha
trovato proprio quelli più famosi di
tutto è primis che sono i più difficili
di tutto è più e quindi non so se ho
fatto una gran cosa probabilmente li
sbaglio tutti per ora jump into the wall
che so l'ho fatta ho fatta subito
veramente non ce la farò mai più ma va
bene son riuscito a prima volta son
contento impossible drive a devo
sopravvivere che ci riprova ci proviamo
con la forza del pen e p1 tonache dolore
ma forte forte proprio il prossimo
l'harpoon questo mi farà che ristorare
che la metà basta ecco perchè non ho
ecco perché ho scelto di giocare primis
in 3d questa volta la volta scorsa c'era
un motivo si era rivelato quasi più
difficile però stai calmo si era
rivelato quasi più difficile provare che
non mi ricordavo come fosse pee wees
normalmente mi sono ricreduto ko parma
facci e addio complimenti la tua abilità
di trapassare le cose ti è servita
questa italiano non morite grazie tommy
sci se muoio ti mando sugli sciiti si
impossible by comici
se per caso usciva la vittoria era forse
la vittoria più bella di tutto happy
meals della storia
non so neanche come cavate va bene sei
calmo
lui sa che facciata perfetto ho vinto
vittoria della vita tratto che si sono
ivelli di tipo 2 3 anni fa addirittura
mica che casino non possimo un per cento
no non l'ho già fatta dai porca eva cero
salta alquanto si cela yes ragazzi ma
basta sono sudatissimo perché ho fatto
una stronzata non dovevo fare questa
cosa non la dovevo fare perché so già
che se vado avanti finisco in livelli
che non riuscivo tipo questo a carissimo
che non riuscirò a fare quindi direi che
posso concludere qui però sono vivo asis
stronzo allora faccio l'ultimo è questo
caso per dimostrarvi che non è così che
sono forte
complimenti santos
centomila like dopo questo spero che
vide vi sia piaciuto ragazzi conclude
episodio credo che finché non usciranno
aggiornamenti di è più visse in 3d
lascialo perdere perché sono sempre gli
stessi quindi ragazzi spero che vi siate
cento e come sentisse videominuto
argomento è un mi piace anche a pagina
di facebook e come la invito a tornare
descrizione sensore city schiacciatrici
vi diano un prossimo video da ragazzi